[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
paul crawford always loved talking to
him former nba player three-time nba
sixth man of the year you surprised by
this news jamal that uh kd wants to stay
in brooklyn
a little surprised by it but i'm happy
with it because that's what they set out
to do when they started this a few years
back so i'm excited it's working out
where they're staying together okay
what's this mean for kyrie
i think
he stays as well i think they say you
know what let's do it we sign together
we want to do this in the first place
let's continue on with this how well do
you know these these two
really well i know both of them really
well i've known them for years
okay but kyrie seems crazy but
calculated
i think they're both really really smart
to be honest with you and they both uh
they both to me are artists there are
two guys who obviously the game of
basketball is first and foremost but the
way they play the game is it's an art to
it
when you're an artist there's always
another canvas to to draw or paint so
they see things a little bit differently
but have so much respect for both of
them okay if i said you could play with
kevin durant or kyrie you had to pick
both no no no no no no jamal
you only get one
i want to play with well if you're going
to brooklyn you're getting both they
decide to stay together
well do you want to play for brooklyn
this year
that was the last team i played for you
know i think
that would have been fun then but i'm at
peace doing tv and coaching my kids so
i'm good with that
um
how would you change
give me the approach that darvin ham can
have with russell westbrook to make a
difference or make him different to fit
in with what they want need well i think
for their whole team i think he'll hold
players accountable
he's a champion he's a guy who played in
the league for a long time he's no
nonsense he's a champion as a coach as
well so with that comes respect as soon
as he walks in the room uh so not just
russ i think for the whole team he'll
demand a certain level of respect and i
think they're responsible well yeah but
russ has to change
right
i think they all have to adjust a little
bit
that's what happens when you get these
stars together there's always a little
bit of give and take and and somebody
may be giving up a little bit more than
the other guys but all of them will have
to sacrifice at some point to make that
ship work but i wonder at a certain age
can you change we we've seen guys who
become you know vince carter became a
three-point specialist or
jason kidd
can russ be
a defensive guy can he be coming off the
bench guy is he capable mentally to go i
can sacrifice my ego
you know what i think russ can do that
as you get older for anybody in the
league i think it's a little harder to
adjust because you're stuck in your ways
but last year i saw a russ in the dunker
i've never seen russ in the dunker or
playing on a team where he didn't have
the ball as much quite as much obviously
when you're playing with lebron his
gravitational pull uh makes everybody
just uh defensively and offensively so
great at it but with russ i think he's
willing to adjust i think he's a winner
he'll do whatever it takes to
help them be a better team this year
what'd you think of lebron signing that
two-year extension
i was happy for him it seems like he
really enjoys l.a um you know it
solidifies his future the next couple
years
uh you know and
you know as a teammate this guy's going
to be here he wants to be here with us
and i think that takes some ease off
some pressure off of everybody
you had your uh summer league games the
uh pro-m in seattle the uh cross over
um yes how do you so how do you get
players
to to show how do you reach out for you
know inviting them lebron and company uh
chet holmgren's there as well so how
does that work you know you got a party
planner that helps you
right you would think so but it at the
beginning it was more guys saying they
want to come and i would just you know
follow up with them and ask them always
ask the kids in the community who they
want to see
and when they tell me i try to go out
and get those guys and it's amazing when
they come
they see it's more than just a pro-am
game it's more than just getting a
sweater getting up and down the kids and
the way they react to them is second to
none a lot of these guys have only seen
you know on tv on espn on tnt
and to see them in person makes
everything realistic for them but a guy
like lebron i have to give a shout out
to dente murray he was behind the scenes
working uh cuffs the legend was behind
the scenes working and then lebron you
know put that tweet out you know what i
may come out there and get a run and
then
it was it was madness from there
what's it like when lebron walks into
the room
it's like
it's it's own thing it's it's own
thing let me tell you a funny story he
was warming up
and our security
is supposed to be protecting him
and lebron's goes to shoot and the
security tries to contest the shot
we need to get security for security
this is ridiculous so he just has a
thing about the world everybody gets
excited so it was amazing to see he had
a great time if people don't think he's
still the face of the the nba they're
crazy all they had to do was see those
people camped out in seattle waiting to
i don't know how many seats you had in
and i don't know how many people you had
to turn away
but it felt like they were there to see
lebron james there's no doubt about it
his his excitement level that he
generates it's like its own thing i i
see grown men turn into kids you see
kids just start crying and they melt
and so it's just amazing to see that in
person you know it's i'm like wow like
you see him as a contemporary you know i
mean played against him for years as a
friend but to see people's reaction who
have never seen him it's uh
see their reaction was just amazing have
you ever had a moment with lebron that
uh
got embarrassed or you got angry at each
other
no no now we've got anger at each other
on the court you know we always have had
moments but i've known him for a long
time i've known him you know for over
two decades so the relationship is
strong there do you have
i talked to football players a lot we're
talking to jamal crawford
do you carry a grudge or like a boxer do
you carry a grudge after you're retired
and you know did somebody hit you below
the belt if you're a boxer or did
somebody cheap shot you in football do
you have a grudge that you carry into
retirement no no grudges at all you know
i kept those grudges on the court for
sure somebody got me i was going to try
to embarrass him i was going to pull out
all
all the crossovers and everything bp but
give me the one give me the one that you
got that you you did get him um the one
where i got him there was a guy i won't
say his name
and i asked him for a pair of shoes when
i was a rookie
and he said yeah yeah i got you as a
star guy i got you i got you and he
never gave him to me and i felt like
like this guy just lied to me and every
time after that i tried to embarrass him
and i got him a few really good times i
won't say his name though
did you ever get the shoes
never got the shoes but
i was okay i i got payback i got a
retribution so i was good there no shoes
though
let's see
anybody want to guess who jamal
paulie what do you think it was his
rookie year yeah that would be what uh
2000
2000 2001 season
2
allen iverson tracy mcgrady
oh it feels like tracy tracy mcgrady do
that to you
no he didn't do it okay that's the deal
friend to this day okay i'll last guess
kevin garnett
no no not kg i love kg actually no i
didn't ask for some one of my favorite
players ever but no it wasn't ticking kg
kg yells at everybody jamal he had
yeah ceo to me and i yelled at him but
he didn't he didn't know that i almost
wore his jersey even in the nba to the
playoffs that a couple years later when
you're playing the lakers and lost
underneath my t-shirt because i love kg
so much so yeah he yelled at me i owe to
him but i had admiration and love for
him that was out of this world
jerry stackhouse that's who did it
no but you guys i'm gonna give you a
little tip you guys were closer when you
said the first three or four names
you're closer in that direction but i'm
not telling you dan i'm not telling you
iverson vince carter
vince carter
yeah you looked up to
you no vince carter i bought the air
ones myself
kobe would have been 44 today
yes what comes to mind when i say kobe
bryant
greatness there's not a day that goes by
that i don't think about kobe and his
family it's just it's amazing because
he's he's always present
whether it's his birthday whether it's
highlights whether it's
um
anything you think of kobe and
his effect and his fingerprints will
always be with us and it's just and for
generations to come
to see kids at the gym you know
three two one kobe and shoot a shot so
yeah he's always with us i think about
him every single day and he's just he
was amazing amazing amazing spirit
amazing amazing person you still go back
to that 81 point game
and i know that we feel like a hundred
is out of the question
but i
i i don't know is it is a hundred points
in a game the way defense's
defense is played down it's a hundred
out of the question
it still feels like it is it really does
but even with kobe i would have probably
told you 80 was out of the question you
know with the way you can load load up
and zones and everything and he got 81
so i don't see it happening in this
lifetime i really don't
but you just never know but even a guy
that's just scorching hot i think at
some point they come triple team like
you know what he's not getting this
record so
you know he has to pass the ball well
jordan had 69 and i think he had he made
one three-pointer
and 18 rebounds that game as well yeah
he's just
he's from a different planet and we know
that he's somewhere else but it but if i
if jordan comes into today's game
yes is he air jordan
he's more than air jordan he's air
jordan with
even more free throw attempts he's air
jordan with even more space he's air
jordan with
a futuristic looking game even how it
was said so yeah he's absolutely
solidified still air jordan and he's air
jordan with social media which changes
the game
but you came to the bowls there like
so the aura that was well that you know
jordan's got a cloud over the nba sort
of like tiger is probably going to have
a cloud over the pga tour like the
ali with boxing a cloud over that
uh gretzky with hockey
yes but
when you came in uh
you're 20 years of age
so
that aura that was still there with the
bulls and mike you know already been
gone
was it there like do you feel it
tangible
i felt it a couple different ways so the
first way i felt it was
the games were still sold out and we
were terrible so they already had
pre-bought tickets in advance because
this guy was so great right
and then just the fact if you walk
around the city it was like the house
that mike built even hearing the
announcer uh you know called our names i
heard that so many times watching the
bulls so
everywhere he went everywhere he wasn't
he was still there like think about it
he still
i'm sure probably the the best selling
guy selling shoes right now and he
hasn't played almost 20 years so
yeah it's just amazing
yeah it's weird that he was playing had
shoes and guys he's playing against were
wearing his shoes
well the coach he was playing with war
shoes have you ever seen anybody where i
saw pj phil jackson where pierre
jordan's why he was coaching chicago
have you ever seen that no
i have not pauly you got one more guest
who jamal has a problem with because
that person promised him shoes his
rookies our final guess would you tell
us if we nailed it
probably not but i would probably smile
a different way okay all right stephon
marbury
no he's not steph
because
but you guys did a great job guessing i
can tell you that you were you were warm
you're really warm and nobody wants to
wear star berries so i can understand
where it's not
now strawberry actually has star rats
funny story actually has strawberries
when you start playing together and he
told me his whole plan and everything i
thought was a brilliant plan for kids
that couldn't really afford him for sure
uh great to talk to you as always jamal
thanks for joining us as well we
appreciate it
thanks dad that's jamal crawford former
nba player three-time nba sixth band of
the year